Jordan peels follow-up to get out if hit
into theatres us is on track for an even
bigger opening to get out but it's not
all about money for the Peter Niang no
it's also about fashion I am drinking
horrible MS a really good excuse to be a
little weird last night in New York
Lupita went for an edgy look and a
seafood studded Beaumont coat and it's
clear she's loving the chance to show
off some fierce fashion and colored
contacts while promoting the film that's
nice pay attention to what you're saying
why not you know just why not and
Lupita's scissoring well it's actually a
nod to the movie me very enraged in us
Lupita's family vacation turns into a
nightmare when they come face-to-face
with evil look-alikes bring somebody
that you know you want to cuddle up with
that's what movies for last night Jordan
brought his wife comedian Chelsea
Peretti's and we're thinking it will be
a long time before their 20 month old
son could see us but in the meantime
Jordans got this they're making another
Toy Story movie I just can't wait until
my son is old enough that I can like
take him through the first three tests I
can be like and guess what boom daddy's
in for
[Music]